in 1922 we see two guys running through
a forest desperately trying to evade an
unidentified creature it is revealed
that three of their friends have already
fallen victim to this creature and now
the two are struggling to outrun it
unfortunately their efforts prove futile
as they eventually get captured and
killed after a while we see the
creature's hand retrieving a wooden
staff that the guys had dropped during
their Pursuit the scene then cuts to the
present time and we are introduced to a
high school student named Zoe cladera
who has recently moved to Australia from
the United States following her mother's
passing she is currently preparing a
meal for her father but she soon gets
distracted when she receives a video
call from one of her friends in Chicago
leading to her unintentionally burning
the food it appears that Zoe still
struggles to Grapple with adapting to
her new life in Australia due to which
she often reminisces about her life back
in the States the next day Zoe and her
classmates prepare for a school trip to
the National Museum on the school bus
Zoe takes a seat beside a classmate
named Owen Clark who is a geek behind
them is a handsome boy of the Class A
Xavier Torres and his girlfriend Caitlin
Fisher there is also a girl named Kaylee
Liu who is a bit quirky and doesn't
socialize much upon arriving at the
Museum they are welcomed by the museum
manager Dr Rawson who guides them
through the exhibits while providing
informative commentary as they explore
the place Zoe walks away from the group
and enters a restricted area where
Kaylee is already chilling soon Owen
joins them and he is followed by Javier
and Caitlin the couple starts having
some lovey-dovey talks which annoys
Kaylee and as a result she tells them to
keep quiet this triggers a small
argument between the two girls while
bickering the same wooden staff from the
opening scene falls on the ground on its
own Zoe picks it up and the staff
mysteriously illuminates displaying five
distinct symbols on each of their faces
before long Dr Ross and apprehends the
group and leads them to her office Zoe
inquires about the peculiar feature of
the staff to which Dr rossen explains
that it Bears an ancient symbol and was
discovered by scientists centuries ago
however these scientists mysteriously
vanished before they could explain
further about the staff furthermore Dr
Rawson unveils another Discovery a cube
with similar carvings to the staff the
group members one after another proceed
to touch the cube which then emits red
light Zoe initially hesitates but is
swayed when she hears her late mother's
voice coming from it prompting her to do
it with everyone's hands on the cube the
entire group including Dr Rawson is
suddenly teleported out of the museum
after a while they regain Consciousness
and find themselves in the middle of an
unfamiliar desert feeling Stranded the
students begin to panic but Dr rossen
reassures and advises them to head
towards a nearby forest in search of
help as they Venture deeper into the
forest they encounter an elderly man
named Marduk covered in Plants upon
seeing them Marduk declares that the
time has arrived he addresses Zoe as an
earth child while the rest are Outsiders
the group doesn't understand what he's
saying but before they can talk further
they hear the roaring sound of a
creature which Marduk claims is from the
guardian of the forest sensing that the
guardian is getting close the group runs
away they Pursuit ensues and Dr rossen
is hit by the beast at first causing her
to be knocked into the ground the
guardian then turns its attention to the
remaining students at one point Zoe
becomes stuck in a tree but just before
the creature can get her she is
inexplicably drawn into the tree a short
while later Dr rossen wakes up and
discovers some Elves playing with her
what she angrily instructs them to
locate the children an order that they
agree to here it's revealed that Dr
Rawson is a sorceress who deliberately
brought the children to this place to
help her in locating the head of the
wooden staff meanwhile Zoe awakens in a
beautiful garden-like setting and finds
Marduk in front of her she also notices
A peculiar symbol on her wrist which
Marduk identifies as the Earth symbol
seeing her confused expression he
proceeds to clarify that she possesses
the abilities of an earth Elementalist
just
self this means she can manipulate
nature and facilitate the healing of
others Marduk then starts to recount a
long forgotten tale he narrates how a
sorceress once served as the guardian of
the tree of knowledge but tragedy struck
her tribe with a devastating plague in a
bid to save her people the Sorceress
used her powers but in doing so she
became corrupted driven to Madness by
her Newfound Powers Marduk and three
other elementalists banished her from
the Tree of knowledge ever since she has
been relentlessly trying to breach the
barrier guarding the tree after saying
all this the old man implores Zoe to
locate the head of the staff before the
Sorceress can reach it overwhelmed and
confused by all of this Zoe departs and
soon runs into Dr rossen the latter
finally reveals herself as the Sorceress
and refutes marduk's story she then asks
Zoe for assistance in finding the
staff's head leaving her torn between
whom to trust nonetheless Zoe decides to
prioritize finding her friends before
delving further into these matters
elsewhere the rest of the group stumbles
upon a location where they are
confronted with a riddle they come to
realize that each of of them is
associated with a specific elemental
power Owen with water Javier with air
Caitlyn with fire and Kayleen with ether
they attempt to Solve the Riddle using
their respective abilities but are
unsuccessful the hell does ether do
anyway soon after Zoe rejoins the group
and explains that the riddle can only be
unraveled when all the elemental powers
unite as a result they combine their
elemental powers and teleport away from
the place I'm half expecting Captain
planet's ass to pop at us somewhere the
group then reaches another part of the
forest where they spot a little fairy
who has injured her wings recalling
marduk's teachings Zoe uses her power to
heal the fairy enabling it to fly once
more after this she proceeds to explain
everything to the group emphasizing the
importance of locating the staff's head
and the tree of knowledge as it's the
only way to save the world and to
facilitate the return home convinced by
her words the group Ventures deeper into
the forest in search of the same after a
while of walking they come across a
humanoid entity who introduces himself
as The Keeper of the crossroad he
mentions that they cannot head forward
without his approval when Owen ignores
his warning and takes a step forward the
keeper freezes him in place and causes
him to vanish from sight Javier then
follows suit and meets the same fate as
Owen seeing this Zoe begs the keeper to
bring her friends back but the latter
asks them to give him something in
return Caitlyn and Kayleen offer him
some money which fails to appease him
resulting in their dismissal as well in
a last-ditch effort Zoe presents him
with her late mother's bracelet which
touches the Keeper's heart recognizing
her pure intention he returns the
precious bracelet to Zoe and opens a
pathway to their intended destination
Zoe then ends up in a snowy forest with
no idea of where to go overwhelmed she
breaks down in tears moments later Dr
Rawson shows up and again asks her to
find the staff's head not long after Zoe
spots Javier who guides her to the
outskirts of the snowy Forest there they
meet a speechless woman with peculiar
facial features who is referred to as
the Weaver she possesses a unique
ability to create anything she wants and
is currently creating grass and trees
Zoe and Javier request her to help to
which she agrees she then transports
them to another location where they
reunite with Caitlyn and Kaylee turns
out the latter two have been brought
here by a guy named unwaver upon
realizing that one of their group
members is still missing Weaver creates
a portal through which they see Owen
being pursued by the guardian Zoe
swiftly pulls Owen through the portal
and Weaver seals it just in time to
prevent the guardian from entering that
evening the group sets up a campfire and
discusses their next move Zoe still
hides the fact that Dr Rawson is the
Sorceress in the midst of their
discussion they hear some Elves coming
to get them due to this they hastily
depart and arrive at a place where all
of them are slowly drawn into the ground
they then find themselves in a Dark
Realm where they are confronted by their
duplicate selves these duplicates
represent their inner guilt or fear
which try to persuade them to join their
counterparts unfortunately Zoe gets
overwhelmed by her fear and guilt
prompting her to succumb to the
persuasion of her reflection after this
she accompanies it through a portal
Caitlyn's reflection also begins to
point out her guilt and fear attempting
to draw her into the portal however
Caitlyn understands its negative impact
and destroys her duplicate self using
her Firepower she then rescues her
friends in the same manner and even
Ventures into Zoe's portal to retrieve
her from the negative world after
successfully passing another face the
group arrives at a beach where they come
across a coffin everyone believes that
the staff is inside it but to their
dismay the coffin is empty just then Dr
Rawson appears in a completely different
Avatar than a museum manager it is at
this moment when Zoe finally discloses
her true identity as the Sorceress she
extends her apologies to her friends for
hiding this fact reasoning that she
didn't know whom to trust meanwhile Dr
Rawson goes on to reveal that she's has
been bringing several groups of children
over the years hoping that they would
unlock the barriers that have kept her
separated from the Tree of knowledge she
admits to manipulating their lives and
deliberately relocating all of them to
Australia in order to regain her power
and access the tree of knowledge she
further threatens the group demanding
their cooperation or else she'll kill
them hearing all this and enraged Kaylee
opens a portal and invites the guardian
to confront the Sorceress the guardian
enters and engages in a fierce battle
with Dr rossen providing the group an
opportunity to escape through the same
portal but soon after the Beast is also
forced back through the portal when Zoe
stares at it for a while she realizes
that it is actually an Earth's child
this means the guardian is one of the
good guys Zoe then uses her elemental
power to soothe it preventing any harm
to the group just then she shockingly
discovers the staff's head stuck within
the guardian's abdomen she then slowly
extracts it but as soon as she does so
both Zoe and the guardian collapsed to
the ground following this rossen
reappears in demands for the staff's
head when the students refuse she
cruelly elect acute Zone and Caitlyn
moments later Zoe Rises to her feet and
surrenders the staff's head to Ross in
exchange for the safety of her friends
after finally getting what she wanted
Rawson takes Zoe and uses the staff to
breach the protective barrier ultimately
leading them to the tree of knowledge
there they find Marduk who serves as the
tree's Guardian through their
conversation it is revealed that Rawson
is none other than his sister when
Marduk comes in her way rossen shows no
hesitation in killing him witnessing
this Zoe tries to use her healing powers
on Marduk but it's of no use before
dying the poor man imparts an important
message to Zoe urging her to let go of
everything as Marduk passes away
unenraged and determined Zoe utilizes
all her powers to destroy the tree of
knowledge Ross and hastily enters the
tree to activate her powers but before
that the tree detonates claiming her
life and bringing an end to everything
in the aftermath of these events all the
group members combine their powers to
grow a new tree shortly after Kayleen
discovers the same Cube which they
collectively touched to get transported
back to their Homeland in the final
scene we see Zoe and Kaylee talking to
each other at school the movie ends as
they realize that they still possess
their extraordinary elemental powers
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching